so the Hong Kong as our government will
vigorously implement this law and I for
one those radicals not to attempt to
violate this law or crossing the red
line because the consequences of
bridging this law are very serious for
years now everyone has joined fellow
members of his party on 1st of July to
mark Hong Kong's hannover Chinese rule
that everything changed last week it
isn't uncommon for such a small peaceful
protest to have hundred-plus police to
search it doesn't offer us I guess this
will be the new norm you may never see
the picture of million Hong Kong s on
the street again not because we are
content or not because we are we are now
happy with the government is because now
we are too afraid to come out this was
the first protest since the new security
law was put in place which can see
offenders go to prison for life for
suppression several parties have now
decided to disband some leading
activists have fled but Avery and his
party are not about to follow suit
because if four political party to bow
down now what's it to say to the rest of
Hong Kong psychologically
most of us are prepared to go to prison
for a long time we are not going to
change what we have been doing for years
but depends on the level subtraction
that we are going to face in the future
there will be certain modification and
transformation of activism in Hong Kong
there's no doubt a strong sense of fear
also looms over supporters
self-censorship has been the most common
reaction just as many pro-democracy
restaurants have quickly taken down
decorations for critical messages
leaving empty memos as a way of silent
protest Beijing insist Allah will affect
only a minority of lawbreakers critics
say political activism is under threat
and that's just the first step
Mina now works for an NGO based in Hong
Kong for decades it has been advocating
for labor rights across Asia Hong Kong
has been a popular hub for thousands of
local and international NGOs but a new
law means many are now reconsidering
their options there is a lot of
ambiguity we don't know what do you mean
by somehow maybe collude with foreign
forces because we have staff from
overseas under this law we are quite
unsure like how it will impact even the
safety of individual staff or what is
the threat for us to if we continue to
receive foreign funding we have to
somehow prepare the worst scenario then
we may also consider to move to
other countries Beijing has played down
the loss impact saying Amelie plans to
strengthen the management of NGOs and
other organizations in Hong Kong even
though its do unclear how the security
law will be implemented activists and
advocates here will have to be where the
phase erupted ero ahead and our
correspondent PB Kong who filed that
report joins us now from Hong Kong
Phoebe in your report we heard of Social
Democrats say many activists are now
afraid because of the new security law
what parts of that law do they fear most
what's particularly concerning is that
outlets we have this morning there's a
warning from the government Hong Kong
hopefully they carry them stating that
they were enforce the law strictly in
recommend vigorously and in terms of law
enforcement we also observe a drastic
change just last night the Hong Kong
Authority laid out a more detailed
implementation to expand police powers
so from now on the Hong Kong police can
search and premises and intercept
communications among people or even
three are anyone's access without and
without courts warrants so this is
pretty much different from the practice
in Hong Kong over the past few decades
which we have checking balances from the
court and all these measures to expand
the police power cannot be challenged by
at court so the citizens simply don't
have any legal way to overthrow the
decisions made by the government so and
this is particularly concerning and
fearful to activists as they fear that
they will be the main targets of the
government and they have no other way to
stop the authority from like in true
including the personal data or safety in
terms of everyday life there in Hong
Kong have you noticed any significant
changes yourself since Beijing imposed
the new security law
but the law has been implemented for
just a week than are we observed there
is a citywide chilling effect and
self-censorship among other than their
citizens that people are now censoring
their own speech online I'm ticking out
comments or post and we also see like
public libraries now starting to remove
books written by activists like Joshua
Wong and apart from that and in terms of
law enforcement according to the rules
implemented just today starting from
today so the police are now are they
empowered to remove or restricts or like
us network providers to remove any
online messages which are deemed as
endangering the national security and so
so we have so like science has already
gave some responses Facebook Google
Twitter and our telegram has already
said they will suspend a request from
the Hong Kong authorities to provide
personal data but in the future we're
not sure whether they can really stick
to their own rules as as this law is
pretty pretty straight and anyone who
failed to comply with me with personal
authority may fail may face jail
sentences Phoebe thank you very much
that was our correspondent Phoebe Kong
in Hong Kong for more let's go straight
over to Joshua Wong he's a prominent
voice in Hong Kong's pro-democracy
movement and joins us from there Mr Wong
Carrie Lam is warning people she
describes as radicals of serious
consequences if they break the new law
does that scare you
shooting effect is generated by Beijing
and it's not only targeting activists
even ordinary citizens or foreigners or
expat live in Hong Kong might also be
the prime target for Beijing to silence
their voice and we Australia where is
not only a political right is also about
the free flow of information and the
free flow of capital being threatened by
bacon since the law is implemented
okay but what about you because you're a
prominent face of the pro-democracy
movement and many people are watching
and wondering
how this affects you have you received
any threats since his law was imposed
with the with the risk of life
sentencing with the uncertainty to
extradite to China with the race always
and always face of being sent to the
black gel in mainland China national
security law is the choose for Beijing
to erode it one country to system to be
one country one system but just like
more than hundred thousand Hong Kong is
talked to the street on July 1st even
police band the rally we still continue
our fight in local in Hong Kong at the
same we also have our friends and seek
for global support ok but I was
wondering about threats to you have you
received any threat I was the I received
fret from pro-beijing camp since last
summer during the anti extradition bill
movement but the French can't defeat us
make us even stronger determination your
fellow activist Nathan law he fled Hong
Kong last week do you intend to stay I
will continue to fight until the last
minute and it's also important to sit
for local and global support at the same
time I will continue the campaign in the
local level and Nathan law will be
responsible for continue the global
solidarity campaign and we wish to let
the voice of Hong Kong is being heard in
the world does that mean you're planning
to stay in Hong Kong then because I
believe you're facing charges there is
that correct with the political
prosecution
I just face the court Rio 24 hours ago
and I still need to go to court on 5th
of August and that's also imply how
Beijing continued to call the mass
arrests and political prosecution in
such city with only 7 millions
population almost 10,000 people were
arrested since last summer and 1,600 of
us were prosecuted including me but in
such a pure battle we still never give
up and on the upcoming primary election
on this weekend we have to send a clear
signal to Beijing kowtow to the
communist region is not an option for us
do you think Carrie Lam has a point
in saying that new security measures are
needed in Hong Kong to avoid the massive
and sometimes violent disruptions we've
seen in the past political crisis mess
up a political system reform escalating
the situation and even allowing police
to call the houses with a search warrant
and override on common law system by the
mainland rule by hotline tactics that's
not the way out no matter what happened
we will still continue to fight for
freedom and also we wish the worked you
know that how the race of Hong Kong
people and expect live in Hong Kong
might be extradited to China and we
might not be serving Joe Sena's in houma
anymore and we might need to serve the
South Joe Sena's in Beijing that's the
phret generated by Beijing live
sentencing is not the things that we
have imagined by activists in the
previous day but that's not an raise the
frets generate by the Communist
authorities okay
the pro-democracy group you used to lead
demos histo that's been disbanded right
as the security law the new security law
was being imposed has Beijing won I
don't want to put my colleague and he
made flight in race even I did as the
risk of life sentencing it doesn't means
that some of more local activists this
need to face the same destiny but even
we are not continue to run as the name
of dam assist oh the activist group that
we belongs to we still continue our
fight in the local level and global
level and we wish have more global
allies to stand with Hong Kong in such
critical moment because time is
collecting in Hong Kong already mr. wall
thank you very much for talking with us
that was Joshua Wong and activist in
Hong Kong thank you well in the wake of
that new security law being imposed
global tech giants have been reviewing
their strategies in the territory the
short-form video app tik-tok has
announced it will exit the Hong Kong
market the move comes after Google
Facebook whatsapp and Twitter stopped
taking requests from users for user data
from home
tik-tok is a Chinese company and has
been trying to grow its global audience
well for more on this were joined by
Clifford Coonan our China analyst from
DW business good to see you Clifford so
tell us why is tick tock a Chinese
company withdrawing its app from stores
from Hong Kong well I think tick tock
because it's a Chinese company which is
trying to expand globally has to show
that it's independent of the China
market and so it has to be more
international than even the more than
even the other international tech giants
so it's made this decision to go even
further than Facebook and Twitter by
actually removing its app from the
stores it has a Chinese wing called
Doble which isn't affected by this but
it shows that they they are very keen to
be to have this international image
they've had a lot of problems with their
image in the last year or so we had a
case last year you might recall where a
Weger girl did a makeup add makeup tic
toc and during the course that spoke
about the the camps the labor camps in
in Shenyang so they've been trying to
improve their image they've hired a guy
from Disney and who's who's now looking
after that side of the business as well
so it's it's it's really part of that
approach is this the first real sign of
the impact that the security law is
having on business in Hong Kong I think
so I mean we heard in the report there
how people are sort of waiting to see
how it'll be implemented and I think
this is an example of the kind of effect
that we're going to see because we've
had these big tech firms and tik-tok
making these decisions now to to with to
withdraw or to review how they're
approaching hong kong and i think it's
going to spill over into other areas now
and it could be that this is going to be
the new normal in hong kong after the
security law
you mentioned facebook and google big
tech firms many of them american it's
quite unusual to see US tech firms of
that size challenging beijing isn't it
it is i mean we're still waiting for
apple apple hasn't made its statement
yet but but the fact that that twitter
and facebook are already reviewing is is
is a very big signal at tik-tok
so I think you're going to see more
pushback now against China if we think
about Huawei we've had the Huawei story
and telecoms for so long in a way this
whole area about what sort of control
the Chinese government can have of
international international companies
when there's a different kind of
different playing fields as it were
between these companies and between
these government controls that's
becoming more and more to the fore and I
think it's going to be played out in
Hong Kong trying to analyst Clifford kun
thank you very much